all right Attorney General William bar
says the decision to force out
protesters near the White House a week
ago was not related to president Trump's
photo-op that evening in the Face the
Nation interview bar also denied a CBS
News report that the president demanded
10,000 active duty troops be deployed on
the streets to shut down protests
nationwide CBS News stands by that
reporting retired general colon Powell
is now backing Joe Biden for president
has been Tracie reports he's one of a
growing number of retired military
leaders criticizing the president we
have a constitution and we have to
follow the Constitution and the
president has drifted away from it
president Trump's response to protests
across the country has top former
military commanders speaking out our
military should never be caught be
called to fight our own people as
enemies of the state the criticism comes
after President Trump talked about using
the military to dominate the streets an
attorney general bill Barr ordered law
enforcement to clear peaceful protesters
out of Lafayette Park across from the
White House last Monday on face bar said
he did not know president Trump plan to
walk through it to stage a photo-op
in front of st. John's Church I gave the
green light at two o'clock obviously I
didn't know that the president was going
to be speaking later that day
he defended the amount of force used
there were chemical irritants the part
no they were not chemical irritants
pepper spray is not a chemical irritant
it's not chemical pepper spray pepper
bulls
a spokesperson for the Park Police told
Vox on Friday that pepper bowls contain
in the irritant powder and chemical
agents that are designed to produce
tears do you believe there is systemic
racism in law enforcement
I think there's racism in the United
States still but I don't think that the
law enforcement system is systemically
racist it's not about a bad apple it's
about a system a system of actors and
those who are complicit with those
actors on 60 minutes last night the head
of the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund
criticized the response to the protests
responding to protests that emanate from
anger about the excessive use of force
with an excessive use of force strikes
me as not a good strategy for law and
order as attorney general Barr reached
out to the Legal Defense Fund know at
any time no
now President Trump continues to call
for law in order even though the vast
majority of protests this past weekend
were peaceful here at the White House
today the president is having a
roundtable discussion with members of
law enforcement but the White House has
not said who will be there or what will
be discussed Gayle I'll take this one
Ben thank you very much